bekele tisser
jamais arrivé de te demander si tu étais
du bon côté
on franchit tout ce lignage rouleau
tellement plus ou moins
ça fait pas de démence pour autant
[Musique]
tu rétabli dans ses fonctions ça tombe
bien parce que là on en a fait autrement
dit pas mal de monde qui t'attend au
tournant et qui rêve mais portera masse
est terminée initiative personnelle
et tu fais tout dans les règles
je suis bien fait comprendre qu'à points
joli discours comment
vous cherchez à couvert
rassemblant guetta pour monter parcours
nature
si vous voir et qu'on pense tous à vélo
je suis vraiment très content d'être de
retour